government can do certain things can
issue certain rules can regulate certain
markets can allowed interesting
companies to be fear or less fear to
move on can detects them or can text
more than of course what it's more
important for the Italian economy is to
regain trust itself in you know the tech
companies to gain trust in themselves
and to keep going with the spirit of
innovation and that they had for so many
years from the 50s 60 70 80 s there is a
crisis of course in Europe as we know I
mean it's the productivity it doesn't
grow as much as we would like the output
industrial output doesn't grow as much
as we would like the internal McMahon is
kind of soft but you know it keeps
innovation in terms of moving things and
I hope the Italian company Diane
communicant in Italian economy large can
find again the spirit of innovation that
was the characteristic that the
characteristic of the economy and the
Italian companies for so many years